okay so on monday a cs go team named
chaos esports club defeated mibr
in hard-fought best-of-three series as
part of cs summit's online qualifier
but almost immediately accusations of
cheating were leveled against chaos
by mostly brazilian fans particularly
aimed
at leaf their youngest player now leaf
started receiving
waves of abuse and even death threats on
social media
he is 16 years old and this has prompted
a crucial question that we
as part of the cs go community need to
try
to answer how do we address the question
of whether or not someone's cheating
without enabling abuse harassment
and death threats by angry unhinged fans
okay guys so as you may or may not know
we are streaming on twitch pretty
regularly these days
so go ahead and head over to twitch.tv
slash the score esports give us a follow
and turn notifications on
and obviously if you haven't already
subscribe to this youtube channel now
the first thing i want to say about this
leaf situation is that i am not here
today
to address the validity of the cheating
accusations that have been leveled
against them
we are here today to talk about the ugly
aftermath
in fact we're not even going to show you
the clips that function as the alleged
proof that this young man
cheated if you want to see them they're
out there and easy enough to find on
your own
because right now the issue is not
whether he did
or did not cheat or has ever cheated
right at this very moment the issue is
how we
as a community address these situations
going forward and how we got to the
point where a 16 year old kid
is being sent death threats from beating
a brazilian team
in a qualifier let's back up for a quick
second to where this all started
after the match on monday leaf tweets
out 2-1 against mibr ggs to them
we all had insane maps plus a little
joke about steel
the replies to that tweet come in hot
and heavy
a lot of them being angry accusations of
cheating from
mostly brazilian fans for those of you
who aren't quite as steeped in your cs
go history
brazilian fans and crowds have a
reputation for being
pretty wild and at times pretty
controversial
land events in brazil feature absolutely
rabid fans screaming for their team and
booing the enemy
and sometimes doing a little more than
that sometimes calling out crucial
information
or making map callouts that would give
their favorite team an unfair advantage
and to be fair they are definitely not
the only nationality
that has been known to do this on home
turf there is a passion to brazilian
fans
that is often celebrated in the cs go
community as it
should be but sometimes that passion
can cross lines in a big way they found
my
my mom and my sister's facebook and they
were literally spamming them
like that same week before i was in the
go of
if you come to brazil we're going to
kill you you know we hate you
brazil hates you and that's exactly what
happened to leaf of chaos esports club
the angry aggressive toxic tweets
started spilling over into outright
death threats
death threats that thankfully have since
been deleted by twitter as they should
be
but if you go to that original leaf
tweet you can see the
hundreds of toxic accusatory
harassing messages and that's only what
we see publicly i think it's pretty
obvious how all of us should feel when
it comes to a
16 year old getting death threats for
beating a brazilian team and an online
qualifier no matter what the
circumstances
but i talked to sadikist about this
entire issue recently and
i think he put it best but i was more
surprised to see the reaction of the
community being so hostile
um and maybe i shouldn't be um
the problem being is that we had players
in this case that have
said not to call people out before
because it does this doing the exact
same thing obviously in the case of
fallen that that's that's pretty true
and i think that
they're a little bit uh
it's hard to say that they still are in
2020 but i think a little bit ignorant
of what they're following is capable of
what
what implications that has this is
unfortunately
nowhere near the first time a cs go
professional
has received death threats from the fan
community
but i think what was really
disappointing is seeing other pros and
influencers add fuel to this fire by
weighing in on whether or not
leaf was cheating in this match the same
day the match took place
tarik who was himself part of the mibr
squad
back at the end of 2018 tweeted several
clips from that match and heavily
implied
that he felt that leaf was cheating
fallen himself chimed in with a pretty
damning tweet as well
and they weren't the only ones either
gaulis a 1.6
pro and a streamer with a massive
brazilian counter-strike audience
piled on his own speculations as well i
mean some of the clips where he's
evaluating whether or not
the players from chaos esports club
cheated have tens of thousands of views
and by the time you see this footage
probably more now are any of these guys
telling
anyone to go out and threaten members of
chaos esports club
no of course they're not but by weighing
in
by implying or outright stating that
leaf or anyone else was cheating
they create a climate where it's okay to
let
accusations fly guys like fallen and
guys like tarik
who are pros and have a massive
following need to be aware of their
influence and it's hard to imagine that
in 2020 that they
aren't and fallen being on a team like
mibr should know that and if you don't
in 2020 then you need to have pr
addressed within the team and the
organizations maybe need to look at it
because
it's hard to imagine someone that's been
around that long
saying oh well you know i can make that
tweet and it's not a big deal no he has
to know that people are going to react
and they're going to take his side due
to his stance in the scene and he has to
know what he's implicating now it's
worth stating that all three guys i
mentioned walked back their original
statements on social media
and asked people not to go out and
harass anyone because of them
but honestly at this point it's too
little too late the damage has been done
pro players and influencers have to
understand that what they say and do
has a huge influence on what fans say
and do
even if they aren't explicitly telling
anyone to actually
do anything by throwing out accusations
like this
they can make certain people feel okay
about taking it too far
this is something the ceo of chaos
esports club greg
laird talked about in a recent tweet
where he said
fallen taric immortals mibr all of your
behavior is unacceptable immature
and does nothing except gathering the
pitchforks of a community
report it to an admin if you think one
of our players is cheating
unbelievable players on other titles are
receiving threatening dms
because of your actions you have a huge
platform use it
responsibly now i did speak to laird the
ceo of krc sports for this story and
although his team wasn't quite ready to
sit down for an interview just yet
he did give me a statement on the matter
which i'll share with you now
the backlash and attitude of the
community against nathan has been
incredibly disappointing
but happily quite a few members of the
community have reached out to offer the
team
and nathan support all i'd like to add
is that pro players and community
members
have large platforms no matter what is
said after the fact
it is very easy for these accusations or
speculations to spin out of control
into very personally damaging situations
for the players and staff
our staff myself and even my girlfriend
have all received
private messages about this that were
less than polite
the team is hard to upset and has
handled the situation very well
all things considered and we've just got
so many examples from cs go's past to
draw on
of players who have been accused of
cheating and who have suffered
personally as a result i mean you guys
could probably name a bunch off the top
of your head
flusha comes to mind rops rops who let's
face it was harassed and bullied
until he literally went to face it
headquarters
and played fpl from there to prove he
wasn't cheating
the people who i looked up to started
calling me a cheater then
it wasn't good i i didn't really want to
play at that point
because it's not good when you look up
to a person and then
suddenly he starts calling you a cheater
just put yourself in
any of these people's shoes you're a
young man you're trying to do what you
love
and all of a sudden you can't turn left
right or sideways
without seeing a horrible aggressive
harassing insensitive message from a
member of the community
because they think you're cheating look
i don't know if leaf is cheating
and neither do you and neither do tarik
fallen
or gallus what we do know is that there
are people out there who will cross
lines who will threaten abuse and harass
pro players when their heroes seem to
give them
implicit permission to do so okay sure
you may have lost that game and
and maybe you're looking for a way to
deflect some of the hatred coming toward
you
um so you you put out this accusation
you gotta you gotta realize we have
proper channels for that stuff we have
admins and they should be the ones to at
least make the decision if someone's
gonna put out an accusation
they should be the ones to do it and the
pro players should know to go through
those channels and keep in mind
a 16 year old kid i mean fallen should
know this more than anyone is trying to
make a living and trying to pursue his
dream within counter-strike
and now he's on the back foot for the
rest of his potential career uh
he's got people that even if he
apologizes even if he's cleared of this
there will be people that just because
they will troll i mean we have people
online that have
large followings that literally that's
all they do and they hide behind a
persona and they harass people and this
will make him
more defensive moving forward less open
to to to being
friendly with the community and maybe
even him you know take the
sweetness out of his mouth for
counter-strike and he might get bitter
about it and not want to pursue i mean
this is it has
huge repercussions for someone who's
essentially still in their formative
years of counter-strike
so usually at the end of the video this
is what we call the end board
we do a gag we show a blooper i talk
about something on my shelf
we give you a little lighthearted
insight into sort of like who we are as
people
but for this one i wanted to actually
say something that's a little bit more
serious
i mean my i myself and some of my
colleagues
have been at times in our careers the
target of online harassment
it just comes with the territory when
you're working in a public way like we
do
when you're on camera when you have a
byline on an article doesn't matter if
you do anything wrong
it's going to happen at some point and
let me tell you it sucks man
it sucks when you have to log on to
twitter or instagram or whatever other
social media
and you see messages or tweets from
people who are saying terrible things
about you
even if you know they're not true and
even if you know these people are just
being idiots
it does hurt it feels bad and i can't
imagine how bad it feels if you're
16 years old so keep that in mind guys
and conduct yourselves
in a courteous professional manner when
you're on social media
behind every avatar no matter if it's a
pro or
an egg with one follower these are
real people with real emotions